restaurantes perdidos
pues bueno les cuento
dicen que cualquiera puede emprender o
por lo menos eso es lo que he escuchado
cada que doy una conferencia
pero la realidad es que conocerla es muy
sincera cuando yo era niña jamás pensé
en emprender es más cuando la gente
venía y me preguntaba qué quieres hacer
de grande en la mente de una pequeña
chepa neca de todas las profesiones que
habían en el mundo jamás pasó a ser la
dueña de su propio negocio
y la verdad es que en un momento pensé
que era una cuestión muy de chiapas muy
del sur pero si se pueden a pensar en
méxico sólo el 26 por ciento de las
empresas están lideradas por mujeres
es más si yo les dieran los ocho minutos
que tengo para la plática del día de hoy
tal vez ni siquiera podrían darme el
nombre de cinco mujeres empresarias en
mexico
entonces
vamos a empezar a aprovechar el tiempo y
les voy a decir y les voy a contar
durante este tiempo para que cuando
alguien venga y les diga juegas como
niña cocinas como niña gordas como niña
ustedes también les digan que no hay
nada mejor que emprender como niño
y es que nacimos para emprender
durante toda nuestra vida crecemos y
creamos herramientas para sobrevivir a
este mundo como mujeres por ejemplo mi
abuela mi abuela crió a cinco hijos e
hijas
mi abuela los mantuvo a todos y con
licenciatura y todo vendiendo perfumes
el negocio de mi abuela nunca fue
estable
de repente caía
de repente se levantaba y era entendible
mi abuela solo tenía la primaria mi
abuela era de una pequeña islita
que está en la costa de chiapas
y ahora no sabía de negocios
pero mi abuela sabía algo mucho más
importante ella sin saberlo sabía de
resiliencia esta habilidad que tenemos
las mujeres para ante cualquier
adversidad
salir adelante porque cuando emprendes
como niña tienes que saber
que no todo va a salir como quieres que
la resiliencia va a ser parte de tu día
a día
pero adivinen qué cuando emprendes como
niña la resiliencia es tu mejor
herramienta para todos los demás
pero hay algo mucho mejor y las
realidades que
cuando emprendes como niña tienes un don
multiplicador les voy a poner un ejemplo
un día estábamos mi mamá y yo soy muy
pequeña
estábamos en la sala de la casa e iban
abajo su bolsa la abrió y sacó dos
billetes de 50 y los puso en la mesa y
dijo bueno la tarea de hoy es que tú y
yo vamos a hacer la lista del mercado
para vivir tres días con estos 100 pesos
la verdad es que para mí ser algo muy
divertido de hacer
y estábamos aquí pensando que íbamos a
comprar donde lo íbamos a comprar cuando
en eso mi tía entró a la casa y que
venía llorando desconsoladamente mi mamá
le ofreció una taza de café y le dijo
siéntete por favor qué está pasando y le
dice diana me corrieron me corrieron del
trabajo
él está tranquila todo va a estar bien
no no va a estar bien porque soy una
mujer grande y ya no me van a contratar
y sabes que es lo peor
lo peor es que soy madre soltera
y entonces menos me van a contratar
y aunado a todo eso
en pocos días mis hijos no van a tener
que comer
dime tú cómo me calmo
mi mamá la quedó viendo
agarró los dientes y le dio uno
para hacerlo es muy sincera yo estaba
muy molesta con uno de nuestros dos
billetes estás viendo que estamos
haciendo la lista y no nos alcanza
y mi mamá jarrón
y le dijo tranquila pasar estos 50 pesos
de bashir al mercado vas a comprar una
bolsa de maíz palomero y vas a regresar
y no te preocupes aquí tengo aceite
tengo gas vamos a hacer palomitas mañana
los vamos a salir a vender y vas a ver
como estos 50 pesos se van a hacer un
dineral
y en ese pequeño momento yo entendí
que las mujeres cuando emprendemos como
niñas sabemos que donde come una comen
dos porque cuando nosotros invertimos en
mujeres para que nosotras emprendamos no
sólo están invirtiendo en nosotras
invierten en nuestras familias en
nuestras comunidades y no lo digo yo en
cifras de la ocde dicen que si tú haces
políticas públicas de inversión directa
a nosotras las mujeres para disminuir la
brecha de desigualdad el país crece un
6% en el pib en promedio
que unos quieren yo sé qué más quiere
catálogo de habilidades qué tal
lo tenemos todo durante toda la vida
nosotros crecemos y se nos enseña a
cocinar se nos enseña a bordar se nos
enseña a administrar se nos enseña a
negociar un catálogo vasto de
habilidades que nos impone la sociedad
pero si lo vemos por otro lado la
realidad es que para las mujeres
emprender es completamente diferente
para nosotras las mujeres emprender no
se trata de un estatus no se trata de
una oficina no se trata de un maletín
para nosotras las mujeres emprender es
tomar decisiones es poder tomar
decisiones para nuestra comunidad es
poder ser visibles
es poder cambiar nuestro entorno
tenemos un catálogo de habilidades
vastas porque las mujeres emprendemos
desde la pasión
y eso hace cosas grandiosas por ejemplo
mariel marialy vive enfrente de lo que
ustedes pueden ver atrás que es el lago
císcar y mariel y tiene un conjunto de
cabañas pero sentía que algo faltaba
para empezar las cabañas no eran de ella
eran de su esposo y de toda la familia
de su esposo raramente hombres no sé por
qué
y entonces maría le dijo yo creo que hay
la verdad es que yo soy muy buena
hablando y yo podría dar unos tours
hitos por hijo pero igual y no lo tengo
que hacer sola así es que mariel y le
habló estás mujeres de su comunidad que
abordaban sí pero también eran buenas
haciendo miel eran buenas produciendo
café y entonces entre todas dentro de
una comunidad se pusieron a dar tours
frente al lago císcar
sí pero chiapas tienden más allá también
de las zonas rurales y tiene cosas en la
zona urbana como carmen carmen que lleva
cinco años trabajando con sociedad civil
dándoles herramientas mediante talleres
y consultorías para que puedan hacer
incidencia en las políticas públicas de
los estados
porque algo muy importante es que si las
mujeres emprendemos desde nuestra pasión
tenemos que seleccionar una sola de
nuestras habilidades y podemos hacer
grandes cosas porque cuando emprendes
como niña tienes que saber que el límite
lo rompes tú y nadie más pero me
encantaría decir que todo el dinero pero
la realidad es que no no todo es dinero
cuando emprendes como niña las cosas de
repente cambian la gente dice cualquiera
puede emprender
pero la gente no sabe que nosotras las
mujeres no la tenemos tan fácil
en un país
donde cada día nos matan a 10 mujeres es
imperante pensar
si realmente el emprendimiento es un
acto romántico
en un estado como chiapas donde cada
días mujeres que trabajan solo a tres
les pagan
nos daría entonces sentido porque la
capital de mi estado de cada dos mujeres
violentadas una es ama de casa señor es
emprender
puede ser debido a muerte
señores para nosotros las mujeres
emprender
también es salir de círculos de
violencia es revalorizar nos de las
mujeres y las habilidades de ser mujeres
grandiosas como lo que somos
y entonces la pregunta que yo les haría
al final de todos estos relatos es que
si no todo es dinero pero habría que
aclarar que es necesario
tendríamos que pensar porque todas las
políticas públicas tanto de gobierno
como de iniciativa privada en lo que en
el caso de los proyectos siempre se
enfocan a brindarnos a nosotras las
mujeres talleres de habilidades
talleres de autoempleo
porque es pobrecito está en su casa y
hay que enseñarle algo cuando nosotras y
se dieron cuenta contamos un tanto con
un catálogo vasto habilidades tendremos
que pensar entonces porque los proyectos
que tenemos para nosotras las mujeres en
temas de emprendimiento siempre se
quedan en el tema micro
porque si las mujeres y les he
demostrado porque si emprendemos como
niñas porque si lo mejor que hay es
emprender como niñas
porque para nosotros todo es así
porque así teniendo la una tasa de
cartera vencida casi nula somos las
mujeres las más pagadoras porque nadie
quiere invertir a gran escala y nosotras
la reflexión del día de hoy no es si
podemos emprender eso a mí me ha quedado
muy claro y espero que ustedes también
la pregunta del día de hoy sería porque
todas las cosas que seguimos haciendo
para nosotras las mujeres están pequeñas
cuando somos mujeres grandiosas
si yo tuviera el día de hoy la
oportunidad
de regresar en el tiempo le diría a mi
pequeña niña a mi pequeña dama que cada
que le pregunten que quieres hacer de
grande le contesté siempre sin dudarlo
emprender como niña muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]